Jamie I'm here it's nice to see you
again my dear lovely nominated friend oh
my what's weird is the first question on
this card that says it's your first
Academy Award nomination for sure and
it's frustrating to me because I feel
like you've been nominated so many times
oh you're sweet every performance I've
ever watched you in is award-winning
worthy but enough of what I think what
do you think how do you feel with this
nomination
you know I just am trying not to have a
sound bite about it I'm trying to
literally tell you honestly not just be
like some little
snippet of something that sounds good
quickly on television but that it it it
it it's too important for me to like
answer it uh quickly it's I have to
think about it I don't think well no no
I can come back to it well no no I'm
just saying I it it requires for me a
process of
what does it mean it's an extraordinary
moment for me as a as obviously as a
woman as a performer
um and it's primarily because of the
Goodwill of so many people who have been
so lovely about it people are just so
genuinely
been
so kind and
um
it was it's been it's it's here's here's
what I figured out and I've said it
before but so I don't want to like
repeat myself I feel like there is a
secret room in my house that I didn't
know was there
that Tuesday morning
opened and I didn't know it was there
and I keep going in the room and I sit
in the room and I'm like
oh my God
and it's just been
it's I think what I'm saying is that I
had walled off
any longing for sure yeah because it was
never going to happen
and then I didn't want my life to be a
disappointment because my life is so
incredible it just was going to be
without that
it's incredible without it yeah of
course and to now have it include that
is just a surprise and a delight and I I
go in the room a lot it's an
extraordinary new room in your house
that you didn't pay contractors for
order exactly it's literally like
papered over and then it was like oh
because it's been there and I'm uh it's
been there of course I just never
acknowledged that it was there it's a
microphone drop right there but I'm I'm
telling you the truth I never I believe
you I never could even imagine it and I
even in the dead of night I can promise
you three years ago in Simi Valley
January 20th when we started shooting
everything everywhere all at once in an
abandoned office building in Simi Valley
California the last thing anybody at
that opening moment was thinking
was that three years later we would be
at the Oscars with 11 Oscar nominations
including Michelle yo and key and
Stephanie and the Daniels and Jonathan
and our editor and the music I mean come
on yeah that wasn't possible that wasn't
in anyone's mind we showed up to make a
movie that the Daniels had created you
can go
what
okay
yeah
to bring everything in 6 p.m
last chance
thank you thank you did you know when
you showed up to that building in Simi
Valley that Michelle was your girl like
you know what I said yes to the movie
because Michelle yo was going to be in
it absolutely true
um and if obviously a fan of her work I
I knew what the part was and I thought
wow opposite Michelle yeah hot dog hands
come on I mean and it was shot in L.A I
don't know if I would have done it if it
was being shot in Georgia I'm being
honest with you but because it was Los
Angeles and Michelle yo was going to be
Evelyn I said yes immediately
um
rituals you got a big award show coming
up a big event do you have ritualistic
songs playlists workouts meals anything
you do before a big event or you just
roll into it hey I'm Jamie Lee Curtis
and I'm here to party I just roll I
don't remember rituals no but I am going
to tell you something because it's
important because I just saw a
reflection of myself in this
these pearls were given to me by my
godparents Edie and Lou Wasserman Lou
Wasserman used to run show business like
he was the biggest Show Business Runner
there was and he was friends with my he
and his wife Edie were friends with Tony
and Janet and so when my sister and I
were born they become our godparents and
over our lifetime you know when we were
young they would give us two pearls a
year for our birthday two pearls a year
for our for Christmas and Tiffany had a
program where you it's called adipurle
where by the end of it you get a strand
of pearls when you become an adult yeah
and I wanted to wear
this as soon as I was nominated the
first thought I had was I get to go to
that lunch not the first thought but
like a thought within the first 10
minutes yeah was oh I get to go to that
lunch I'm gonna wear Edie and lose
pearls how incredible
um to bring my parents and to bring my
godparents and the legacy of my family
with me to the to the Oscar luncheon so
that I'm I'm wearing something that
has a a real time
link for me yeah that's incredible and
what a story so that's no idea about
that's what that's how I prepared today
today I prepared that way
um on the actual day
I'm sure there'll be some other Talisman
of connection for me to someone or a
friend or a family member
um
that's important to me I mean I'm not
you know that's got to connect the dot
actually you know what it'll be it'll be
a ring that Michelle yeoh gave me which
is a our Bagel it's in the movie you
know the bagel universe so there's she
gave me a pretty ring with a circle and
so I'm sure I'll wear that ring to again
Bring It full circle because the reason
I'm here is Michelle yeah yeah I mean
literally the reason I'm sitting here
talking to you is Michelle yeah I love
who you are in her corner right now it
is just she's I believe you I'm gonna
let you get out of here in a second fine
but not until you tell me
about and tell me if I'm pronouncing it
wrong
K Scarpetta no there's nothing for you
that's my lunch
the prize you walked in our ET room
earlier to use the bathroom and you said
you wanted to join our pizza party and
we don't want you to feel left out
um
because why would I eating the lunchroom
I'm
so happy oh my God I love you
I know
we want you to eat we want you to have
nourishment so you can go forward and
accept all these nice compliments these
beautiful people are going to be I'm so
hungry
there has not been a moment
[Music]